une première mondiale à l'hôpital henri
mondor de créteil une greffe réussie sur
trois personnes atteintes de la maladie
de huntington une affection génétique
qui provoque la démence puis la mort il
s'agit d'une greffe de cellules foetales
implantés directement dans le cerveau
une opération déjà pratiqué pour
certains patients atteints de la maladie
de parkinson
on va essayer de lui mettre des cellules
nerveuses tout neuf très jeunes qui ont
été prélevés dans le cerveau de ces
foetus mort au décours des ivg les
cellules étant encore vivante pendant un
certain nombre d'heures on va aller
prélever et puis on va les introduire
dans le le cerveau du patient dans
lequel elles vont s'installer et elles
vont essayer de reconstruire des voix de
connexion qui ont été interrompues
pascal est l'un des trois patients avoir
subi cette opération
aujourd'hui il va beaucoup mieux il
n'est certes pas guéri mais cette grèce
réussit lui laisse quelques répit elle
va redonner aussi espoir aux 6000
personnes qui en france souffrent de
cette maladie